[Musik]
die ereignisse der vergangenen nacht
sind ein wendepunkt in der geschichte
europas und unseres landes
ein präsident und ein land im
krisenmodus krieg in der ukraine hohe
energiepreise soziale spannungen in
unsicherer zeit muss frankreich sich
entscheiden wer das land künftig führen
las in der ukraine geschieht geht uns
alle an es ist auch unsere freiheit die
auf dem spiel steht
es ist krieg in der ukraine damit sind
wir nun konfrontiert aber wir müssen
auch weitermachen
[Musik]
in einer notunterkunft bei paris
präsident marco begrüßt demonstrativ vor
kameras einen ukrainischen jungen und
dessen mutter marco der tröster makro
der kümmerer marco der krisenmanager
im pornokino wir werden alle beschützen
die in unserem land ankommen soll das
ist marco der staatsmann die prächtige
kulisse von versailles ist für den
eu-gipfel sorgfältig gewählt sie
suggeriert historische bedeutung
debatten mit präsidentschafts
konkurrenten vermeidet micron derweil
seine auftritte auf der weltbühne wirken
auch so für ihn
der krieg nutzt mahkorn ab denn er hat
den effekt dass sich die franzosen um
die fahne scharen wie immer ein krisen
und anders als seine herausforderer kann
er die internationale karte
der krieg überlagert frankreichs
probleme probleme die makro in seiner
zeit als präsident nicht gelöst hat
[Musik]
marseille eine der ärmsten städte des
landes und einer der gefährlichsten sie
steht für verfehlte sozial und
integrationspolitik für ghettos und
gewalt
vor den toren der hochhaustürme ein
illegaler markt eine parallelwelt mit
eigenen gesetzen
dealer bauen barrikaden auf blockieren
die zugänge zu den berüchtigten vierteln
im norden der stadt für außenstehende
es brauchte mehrere anläufe bis nachher
und armin einwilligen uns dorthin
mitzunehmen sie zeigen wo sie
aufgewachsen sind eine siedlung der vor
allem einwanderer der zweiten und
dritten generation wohnen
hier gibt es so viele des staates die
wohnverhältnisse im nahverkehr
sicherheit zugang zu bildung zu
öffentlichen einrichtungen
abgeschieden von der außenwelt ohne
perspektive es gebe kaum chancen den
alltag zu entkommen
türme mit je 21 stockwerke sechs
wohnungen pro etage hunderte familien
leben hier zusammengepfercht dass wir zu
gewalt und zu spannungen
der staat hilft uns das fehlen das
ferienangebot
und was machen die jugendlichen dann sie
versuchen sich irgendwie alleine durch
zuschlag an den betrogen die
kriminalität
fürs schmiere stehen bekommen speer 150
euro am tag mehr als der mindestlohn der
eltern doch mit der kriminalität wächst
die gewalt die gefahr für alle im
viertel wie im vergangenen herbst
gerechtigkeit für rajan fordern sie
rajan wurde 14 jahre alt die polizei
geht davon aus dass er opfer einer
schießerei unter drogenbanden wurde
getötet von den kugeln einer
kalaschnikow als er mit freunden vor
seiner haustür stand
[Musik]
die potash corp wir sind nicht alle
dealer nur weil wir in diesem viertel
wohnt unsere kinder werden von
verbrechern getötet und wir werden dafür
auch noch stigmatisiert
egal was passiert wir sind immer schon
wir sind es die zerstören die
beschmutzen die stelen und die tür
vor allem erschlägt solche töne an der
rechtsextreme erik sem uhr mehrfach
wegen hetze verurteilt besucht marseille
dass ich es im uhr ich heiße moment und
ich bin in frankreich geboren sind leute
wie ich in ihren augen franzosen
diese frage ignoriert so moore ebenso
wie die rufe am straßenrand
10 uhr verschwinde marseille gegen
rassisten
er provoziert um sich zu profilieren so
moore zeichnet marseille als
abschreckendes beispiel ist
ein symbol wenn man nichts tut wird ganz
frankreich
frankreich wird überflutet voneinander
wird islamisiert
eric ist er mur ist der scharfmacher im
rennen um das präsidentenamt
er bedient die nostalgie nach einem
frankreich dass es nie gab
rückeroberung heißt seine partei zehn
uhr will ein abschiebe ministerium
als aller erstes werde ich dem zustrom
an migranten stammen neue migration wird
ganz klar das ziel meiner politik sein
[Applaus]
hier sind hier zuhause lautstark
unterstützen sie den rechts identitäten
[Musik]
der damit zur konkurrenz für marine le
pen wird bislang besetzte sie allein den
rechten rand der republik neben simor
wirkt le pen für viele franzosen bei der
hall gemäßigt trotz harter töne
ja es gibt eine verbindung zwischen der
zunehmenden unsicherheit rund der
migrationswelle
die unkontrollierte migration macht aus
unseren straßen vierteln städten und
französische zone um bildung fort
[Musik]
in der präsidentschafts kampagne geht es
nur darum wer den größten unsinn über
einwanderung verbreitet wer die größte
aufmerksamkeit bekommt wenn es um den
islam geht und der wird dann gewinn
laut umfragen würde ein drittel der
franzosen im ersten wahlgang für einen
rechtsextremen kandidatin stimmen im
zweiten wahlgang sogar fast die hälfte
das setzt auch die konservativen unter
druck valerie pecresse kandidatin von
lee repubblica soll die frühere
volkspartei zurück zur macht führen
sie übernimmt dafür die parolen der
rechten ihre politik für die prekären
viertel in marseille härte statt hilfe
[Musik]
ich verfolge die clan chefs die gauner
die dealer die hassprediger ihnen will
ich die bürgerrechte nehmen ich werde
den hochdruckreiniger rausholen
ich werde oft gefragt warum geht er jung
nicht wer aber warum sollten wir wenn
sie uns mit dem hilft druck reiniger
verjagen wir sind wir für
die radikale rhetorik spaltet das land
und sie erschwert die suche nach
lösungen
vergangenen herbst erst zum ende seiner
amtszeit hat emanuel makudi nordviertel
von marseille besucht er traf auch armin
und las er
[Musik]
der präsident kam mit versprechungen 15
milliarden euro für bildung wohnraum und
für die polizei 300 zusätzliche
einsatzkräfte sollen eingestellt werden
jede beliebige starts in frankreich
behandelt
sonst würden die bewohner weiterhin all
diese probleme erdulden müssen sonst
gäbe es keinen fortschritt wieder für
marseille noch für das land will
man wird erst in einigen jahren wissen
und dieser plan erfolg hatten aber er
gibt ihm bereits die möglichkeit seine
politik für der kommenden fünf jahre zu
inszenieren
für den kandidaten makro bleiben
integrationsfragen und sicherheitsfragen
jedoch echte schwach die meisten
franzosen sind mit dieser politik
unzufrieden ist
makros versprechen das war auch mehr
markt weniger staat als liberaler
reformer er einst angetreten doch die
bilanz ist gemischt
[Musik]
auch unter mark rohr fließt reichlich
öffentliches geld um unternehmen und
arbeiter durch krisen zu bringen der
autobauer renault hat einen 5 milliarden
euro kredit bekommen während der cupid
pandemie
[Musik]
jolanda viele arbeitet erst seit kurzem
im werk von du über ein öffentliches
förderprogramm ist sie an den job
gekommen
viele krise klug uri seit der korona
krise war es schwer arbeit zu finden
gerade für mich als leiharbeiterin
und als ich erfahren habe dass hier im
renault werk ein neues projekt startet
habe ich gedacht das ist doch eine gute
möglichkeit
die arbeitslosigkeit im land ist
deutlich zurückgegangen macros ziel 7
prozent ist greifbar nah trotz pandemie
ortstermin beim autobauer ein präsident
feiert sich für seine politik
wir schaffen neue arbeitsplätze
weil wir wieder investoren anziehen das
arbeitsrecht und die besteuerung von
investitionen reformiert haben die
produktions steuer gesenkt haben und die
unternehmenssteuer senken werden ein
aufschwung mit abstrichen denn der
rückgang der arbeitslosenzahlen stützt
sich wie bei yolanda vielfach auf
prekäre beschäftigung sie erhält kaum
mehr als den mindestlohn der in
frankreich bei 1270 euro im monat liegt
und sie hat nur einen befristeten
vertrag
ich hoffe dass ich einen unbefristeten
vertrag bekommen kann damit ich ein paar
persönliche pläne machen kann ich hoffe
wirklich dass nicht nach einem jahr
wieder schluss ist
welche pläne sind
die arbeiten am haus zu ende bringen ein
auto kaufen vor allem auch mal verreisen
wie viele waggons trifft
[Musik]
der industriell geprägte norden
frankreichs hat in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten viel durchgemacht firmen
wanderten ab oder gingen bankrott in
dieser fabrik in amir wurden als
wäschetrockner gebaut sie spiegelt die
andere wirklichkeit der französischen
wirtschaft france war und christoph
gewerkschafter haben bis zuletzt für
ihre kollegen gekämpft vergeblich
der eingang zugemauert schicht ende für
immer
das ist die mauer der schande
wenn man sich überlegt dass wir hier 30
jahre ein und aus gegangen sind fragt
man sich schon wie das passieren konnte
der us konzern kehrte frankreich den
rücken andere firmen siedelten sich an
dem standort an und scheiterten
hier sagt keiner makro habe frankreich
nach vorne gebracht im gegenteil
meiner meinung nach wird das böse enden
das ist so gut wie sicher
wir haben es schon bei den gelb westen
gesehen dann die straßenblockaden der
lkw-fahrer da tut sich
an dem tag an dem wir die nase voll
haben gehen wir auf die straße
selbst den sozialisten seit jeher an der
seite der arbeiter schenken sie kein
vertrauen
die suche
allein schon wenn ich sehe mit wie
vielen kandidaten sie angetreten sind
sie spalten sich damit doch nur selbst
für mich ist es auch egal ob die linken
oder die rechten regieren sie sind doch
alle gleich wo muslime durch ökonomie
der wirtschaft mag es gut gehen aber wir
kleinen leute wir armen haben nichts
davon profitieren nur die reichen die
reichen werden immer reicher und die
armen bleiben ihre styropor restaurant
bohren
was viele hier makro übel nehmen ist
dass er steuern auf kapitalerträge
gesenkt hat um die wirtschaft
anzukurbeln
das etikett präsident der reichen wird
er hier im norden nicht los
[Musik]
dies ist eigentlich nur für ihn gut
gelaufen gute bezahlung der vorteile ihm
wird sicher super wir haben nichts davon
merken
sie mühen sich ab und fühlen sich doch
abgehängt vom aufschwung wir treffen
yolanda noch einmal nach feierabend jobs
und einkommen sind für sie das
wichtigste thema bei dieser wahl
[Musik]
ich bin eine arbeit
wir wollen natürlich dass die kaufkraft
steigt
wir sind so viele und wir sind es doch
die die wirtschaft ankurbeln nicht sie
die politiker
[Musik]
unsere arbeit und unserem gehalt
diese stimmung könnte eine steilvorlage
seien für die sozialisten ist es aber
nicht
unterwegs mit anni dallgow die
bürgermeisterin von paris kandidiert für
das präsidentenamt sie will soziale
ungleichheit bekämpfen und verspricht
etwa die gehälter der lehrer zu
verdoppeln
eine ihrer ersten stationen in diesem
wahlkampf janak geburtsort von françois
mitterrand seit langem befindet sich die
partei des früheren präsidenten im
niedergang die kranzniederlegung an
seinem grab eine jährliche tradition hat
in diesem jahr etwas symbolisches
spreche viel mit meinen parteikollegen
darüber ja es stimmt in der geschichte
im leben meiner politischen familie
hatten wir noch nie so eine schwierige
situation
das liegt auch an der konkurrenz im
linken parteien lager sechs kandidaten
werben um dieselbe wählerschaft die sich
sorgt um kaufkraft und soziale
gerechtigkeit
diese sorge wächst warum bringt ihnen
das nicht mehr stimmen
wir kümmern uns um bildung das
gesundheitswesen kaufkraft die gehälter
wie sehr niedrig sind in frankreich
glover ich denke dass die franzosen das
erkennen je näher der wahltag von lise
lemonnier frostig ida gehofft dass sie
ähnlich wie olaf scholz in deutschland
am ende besser als erwartet abschneiden
doch die sozialen forderungen ihrer
partei werden von anderen linken immer
wieder überboten
hörde die ich widme diese versammlung
auf dem platz der republik den
widerstand des ukrainischen volkes gegen
die russische invasion
[Musik]
jean luc mélenchon will die lücke füllen
die anika buhl es mit einem radikal
linken programm mindestlohn weniger
arbeitszeit höhere steuern für
gutverdiener und rente schon ab 60 aber
ihm kommt der krieg in der ukraine
dazwischen seine solidarität widmung
widerspricht dem was er bis vor kurzem
noch sagte
chiquita schienen sich die usa haben
beschlossen die ukraine in die nato zu
annektieren und russland fühlt sich
vergessen und bedroht weil wir eine
raketenabwehr in polen aufgestellt haben
viel kritik für die nato und viel
verständnis für putins russland wir
fragen mit ausschau nach seinen
bisherigen positionen
haben sie die gewalt von wladimir putin
unterschätzt nein im gegenteil ich habe
sie vor allen anderen begriffen vor zehn
jahren habe ich das schon vorausgesagt
aber sie haben doch bislang immer die
nato kritisiert und die sanktionen gegen
russland warum
da endet mit chance auskunftsfreude
erprobt
von den großen kundgebungen in paris und
von der weltpolitik sind sie hier weit
entfernt
in restaurants geben tradition und
konservative werte den ton an
[Musik]
katri ist trüffel beuren und gehört zur
bruderschaft des schwarzen diamanten wie
sie die trüffel hier nennen
bonus euro person für uns steht das hier
vor allem der beziehung zur erde für
authentizität für respekt von der
tradition und französisches know how
und so ist die jährliche messe für die
trüffel und ihren schutzheiligen ein
doppeltes bekenntnis zum glauben und zur
rolle der kirche die sie in anderen
teilen des landes so nicht mehr hat
[Musik]
ich denke die säkularisierung prägt ganz
frankreich aber wir sind hier in der
ehemaligen enklave des papstes wir haben
eine reiche geschichte und geschichte
ist nicht nur vergangenheit vielleicht
lebt in den kleinen dörfern auf dem land
die tradition stärker für die kirche ist
hier heute noch sehr präsent im leben
der männer
der marktplatz von resch produkte die
die menschen hier stolz machen viele
sehen nicht nur eine räumliche distanz
zwischen sich und den volksvertretern in
paris
ich denke politiker in paris verstehen
nicht wie man hier auf dem land lebt es
gibt eine lücke zwischen ihnen und der
wirklichkeit des lebens hier
politiker kommen nicht aus der schule
des lebens das sind leute die elite
schulen besuchen und jetzt wollen sie
uns beibringen wie das leben
im zentralistischen frankreich fühlen
sich die menschen auf dem land zurück
gesetzt das heißt politikverdrossenheit
andré schembri wünscht sich dennoch
jemanden im élysée der oder die die
distanz überwindet er
sollte ein präsident sein oder eine
präsidentin der gute ideen mitbringt die
erträge der französischen erde reicher
zu machen der unser können voranbringt
und unsere traditionen bewahrt sie mit
großer tradition
[Musik]
reiter treiben bullen den strand entlang
die corrida in der camargue ist ein
volksfest anfang märz marine le pen ist
gekommen die traditionspflege soll einen
bildstarken rahmen bieten für ihre
präsidentschaftskandidatur der auch le
pen wird immer wieder auf den krieg in
der ukraine angesprochen
zur sicherheit der atomanlagen in der
ukraine
emanuele man überlegt wie man die
sichern könnte
dazu habe ich nichts zu sagen
der krieg in der ukraine ruft in
erinnerung dass le pen sich stets ihrer
guten kontakte zum nadim er putin
gerühmt hat sie hat auch mit russischem
geld an den wahlkampf finanziert und
putins russland immer wieder in schutz
genommen
die ersten maßnahmen die ich gegenüber
russland ergreifen würde wären die
aufhebung der sanktionen zu erwägen da
ich immer gegen diese sanktion war es
sich sowohl ungerecht finde wie
kontraproduktiv
heute bringt der krieg in der ukraine le
pen in die defensive wir fragen nach
sie sind die einzige kandidatin bei der
präsidentschaftswahl die jemals geld
genommen hat aus russland schwächt sie
das macht sie das heute angreifbar
ich habe kein russisches geld genommen
ich habe ein darlehen einer russischen
bank dass ich weiterhin zurück wenn sie
mir eine deutsche bank empfehlen können
nämlich die sehr gerne große
le pen will das thema hinter sich lassen
sie hat teile ihres programms gemäßigt
aus der eu etwa will sie nicht mehr
austreten sie verspricht steuersenkungen
und mehr hilfen für die arbeitende
mehrheit immer wieder attackiert sie
makro wie in diesem radiointerview
was die einheit des landes angeht ist
die lage katastrophal
warum selbst hat beigetragen sich neben
sozialen krisen die die franzosen
spalten
[Musik]
le pen will die stimmen der
unzufriedenen sammeln sie stellt sich
als hauptkonkurrentin makro star als
einzige die ihn schlagen könne
sie haben heute nur eine einzige
kandidatin die sich gegenüber makro
einigermaßen behaupten kann weil sie auf
traditionelles wahlverhalten und die
mobilisierung der arbeiterklasse setzt
und das ist le pen
[Musik]
im lehman usa konkretisiert den
moralischen und politischen zynismus
platini putins in bezug auf humanitäre
korridore der krieg in der ukraine und
die folgen begleiten auch victor krebs
krebs ist becker im elsässischen
reichshof und braucht sein auto für
auslieferungen seit kriegsbeginn steigt
der preis fürs benzin krebs spürt das
will aber nicht nur ans geld denken
sutil ich bin bereit mehr zu zahlen wir
brauchen wirklich die aktion ich denke
wir dürfen die sanktionen nicht zu
schwach wir sollten aufhören bestimmte
dinge in russland zu kaufen und sie
woanders besorgt
[Musik]
die kaufkraft ist ein wiederkehrendes
thema im französischen wahlkampf wegen
des kriegs gewinnt es an dringlichkeit
krebs will einen mitarbeiter vertrag der
ausläuft nicht erneuern wegen der
unsicherheit und um höhere kosten
abzufangen
ich kaufe man will in frankreich und nur
in frankfurt aber der preis für mehl
wird in amsterdam festgelegt an der
börse
wurde also steigt der preis auch wenn
wir unser mehl nichts mit dem mehl aus
der ukraine oder russland zu tun
ich habe all meine für dieses jahr
geplanten investitionen gestoppt alles
ist
in frankreich spielt der staat
traditionell eine große rolle im
wirtschaftsleben und in der krise
erwarten die menschen mehr denn je hilfe
die lebenshaltungskosten steigen vor
allem das benzin für autos das ist ein
echter luxus im moment bald gehen wir zu
fuß und schieben das auto
sie müssen die steuern auf benzin so
geht's nicht weiter die 100 euro
inflationsausgleich die es gab sind
schon lange ausgegeben
inflation ist ein explosives thema seit
den protesten der sogenannten geld
besten gegen hohe benzinpreise
frankreichs regierung tut alles dass
sich solche bilder nicht wiederholen sie
gibt mehr als 20 milliarden euro aus um
energiepreise für verbraucher und
unternehmen abzufedern
hat je nach lage seine farbe gewechselt
wie ein chamäleon ursprünglich war sein
programm liberal im laufe seiner
amtszeit wurde die rolle des staates für
ihn in den krisen immer wichtiger
tieferen krise
machen kündigt an im fall seiner
wiederwahl das rentenalter auf 65 zu
erhöhen sozialhilfeempfänger sollten
sich fortbilden müssen ansonsten will
auch macao dem land nicht mehr allzu
viel zu
wir fragen ihn sie waren angetreten
frankreich zu reformieren damit die
menschen weniger vom staat abhängig sind
jetzt gibt es in der krise all die neuen
staatsausgaben sind sie da gescheitert
ich glaube nicht denn wir haben ja
wichtige bereiche reformiert ich habe
reformiert um energien freizusetzen
damit sich dinge entwickeln könnte
daneben habe ich immer dazu gestanden
dass wir in frankreich ein sozialsystem
haben dass menschen beschützt in zeiten
der krise
makro der beschützer der kleinen leute
manche nehmen ihm diese rolle nicht
recht erhöht
herr präsident guten tag eine frage was
tun sie für die kaufkraft wenn ich als
familienvater ich bin 46 ich kann nicht
von meinem einkommen leben finden sie
das normal
ist die usa der zur kaufkraftsteigerung
haben wir 20 milliarden
richtig ich bin mit ihnen einverstanden
herr präsident aber ich habe nichts
davon weil ich keine ansprüche haben ich
zahle immer nur
frankreich zwischen alltagssorgen und
weltpolitik das land ringt mit sich mit
seinen problemen und darum wem es am
ehesten zutraut sie zu lösen die
vielzahl der krisen und der krieg machen
den ausgang dieser wahl
unberechenbar